[Music]
hey what's up everybody my name is
clinton jones and you're here to learn
a very important compositing technique
when trying to color match different
pieces of footage together now this is
especially important
for color blind vfx artists such as
myself now when i was in elementary
school top gun was my favorite movie
and i wanted to be a jet fighter pilot
but the nurse pulled me aside and said
hey
you're color blind go home and i had to
decide what am i going to do with my
life
and i decided to get into filmmaking
which actually kind of worked out
because i could just
fake being a fighter pilot
[Music]
[Music]
so i am red green deficient and blues
are a little
violet to me which basically means i
can't see any of these
numbers hidden inside of these images
now if you can't see the numbers either
then you might be colorblind too
take a test at some point but we're here
to to figure out a way
over that hurdle when it comes to color
matching different pieces of footage
different assets different plates
together to make them look like they
blend and live together
in the same shot big thanks to parsec
for sponsoring this video
stick around to the end to figure out
how you can remote log into your
workstation from
anywhere in the world now let's get
started alright so we got sheila beef
in my living room you guys have seen the
footage before it's green screen footage
so i pulled the key
i tracked him into the living room i
even added a little shadow on the back
wall here but that's not why you guys
are here
uh we're here to color match him to the
actual footage
so all i'm going to do is just apply a
levels effect to his layer
he looks a little washed out and i think
he looks a little blue but that's just
that's just me guessing after all these
years of color correcting footage like
this
um so in the levels effect under channel
let's go ahead and change that to red
alright so we're just adjusting the the
red
channel so it doesn't behave normally
like when you're in the rgb version of
levels
so i'll switch to red and i'm going to
take this little button right
here and i'll toggle red so now i'm only
viewing
the red channel on our footage so
basically i'm going to go through each
channel and color correct
in black and white alright so i'm just
going to match this up
i'm seeing that the black border of this
picture frame is a little bit darker
than
his black shirt or this dark shadow down
here on his pants
so i'm going to make that adjustment
so it looks about right and what we can
do as well is up here in the top right
under the info tab
you have hsb hue saturation and
brightness so we can reference the
brightness of that
picture frame with 13 we can go down to
the shadow
seven percent so it's maybe a little
dark come
up and i think his skin is a little
bright so we'll bring that down
just a little bit maybe somewhere in
there
so next we'll move on to the green
channel okay
so you have to make sure that you switch
over to the green channel in the levels
as well
now let's make those adjustments again
the picture frame it's a little too dark
compared to shia's like shadows and
stuff so i'm going to crunch that down
but not too much
that feels about right
now his skin is probably somewhere in
there
and you just want to make it seem like
he fits like if it was a newspaper print
you want to make it to seem like he
actually fits
into the environment in this black and
white grayscale version
and finally we'll go to the blue channel
switch it on the levels
now this always looks the weirdest
because there's not really any blue
in skin tone so it's gonna feel a little
funky
but you just gotta make it match the
background
so we'll bring that down bring that down
a little bit more
and let's see what that looks like when
we switch back to rgb
i think that's good i mean again color
blind can't really tell
but it feels better to me than the
original this is the original
and this is uh the adjustments that
we've made
now you can always throw on like a hue
and saturation
and drop the saturation just a little
bit if you feel that's necessary
but another way of doing this is
actually to
have someone stand in who is a similar
complexion
and you can actually uh go through all
those different modes right each channel
and match their skin tones so that'd be
another way of doing it all right i just
want to clear up two things
one i do not see in black and white
that doesn't happen when you're
colorblind actually it's very rare
it's extremely rare it can happen but
the majority of the cases
is not the case all right and second no
red is not green green is not red color
is not inverted for me
um i i can actually drive i can tell the
difference between a red light and a
green light
while i got you guys here i just want to
say a big thanks to our sponsor
parsec for making this possible parsec
is a powerful remote access application
that allows you to access your
heavy-duty computer from anywhere
in the world i use it to render on my
work pc so i can keep working on other
shots from home
now the reason i think parsec is a
perfect sponsor for this video
specifically
is because parsec warp their new service
actually has
a 444 color mode that means that every
single pixel
on your computer is a specific color
every pixel is accounted for so you're
getting the most accurate and detailed
color
possible i've been using this service
actually before they reached out to me
so i think it's freaking awesome and you
actually get with parsec warp you get
two monitors working at the same time
and not only that
it works with your tablet as well if you
guys know i use a tablet all the time i
don't own a mouse
so parsec warp is like it's like heaven
for me when i'm trying to get videos
done
at corridor but i'm working from home
because of the pandemic right
so go check it out parsec it's actually
free
warp is only 10 bucks a month my name is
clinton jones i am the punisher
subscribe
if you're not subscribed already we're
always learning and growing together so
i will see you guys
you